嗯，
不要以为说老年人一定是跟自己的亲儿子亲闺女关系就怎么怎么样嘛，
他未必人老了之后跟小孩一样，
谁跟他玩儿能玩到一块儿去，
谁跟他逗闷子，
谁给他糖吃，
谁哄他开心，
他就跟谁亲。
我这边是四线城市，
我是农村家庭，
我是独生女，
那妈妈29岁的时候才生的我，
对方独生子，
父母离异，
各自再婚，
且没有孩子，
他跟他爸爸，
我妈妈呢，
从小对我管理的就比较严格，
就不让我穿裙子呀，
也不让我跟男孩子说话那种，
他从小就开始喜欢我，
就很会花言巧语，
我们谈恋爱，
后来被我妈妈知道以后呢，
她特别的不同意，
也非常的生气，
就说他爸爸好吃懒做，
就说他家风不好，
后面呢，
我们在一块呢，
我慢慢的也发现他喜欢骗人，
我就不想跟他在一起了，
但是呢，
我们又稀里糊涂的订了婚，
结婚比较早，
我属于一直跟他来回的耗着，
后面呢，
我妈妈身体呢就不太好了，
家里的亲戚呢就劝我赶紧结婚，
特别是我的外婆，
她觉得我花钱大手大脚，
她觉得如果我嫁到我们那边市里面呢，
别的婆婆可能会看不惯我这样子，
她就想让我跟她结婚，
因为她住我外婆家的楼上，
我外婆觉得就住楼上楼上。
就相当于没有嫁出去，
看看我妈妈的身体能不能赶紧的好起来，
我就结了，
她每天都要喝酒，
一个人在家里面也要喝，
又抽烟，
我对他就属于生理性的讨厌了，
我当时想的呢，
就是我妈妈病好了，
我就要跟他分手，
身边的人都结婚了，
都有孩子了，
我一直就没有消息，
因为我当时就想的就是我后面会跟他分手的，
我不想害我的孩子。
我们是2015年结了婚，
受不了这个压力，
我就怀孕了，
2017年的时候呢，
生了我这个女儿，
我家里有回迁房两套，
对方家里呢有回迁房四套，
我们2015年的时候办婚礼之前呢，
他们家卖了一套房子，
说要办婚礼，
2016年呢，
我陪我妈妈在外地治疗的时候呢，
他们家又卖了一套，
卖完以后呢，
我们才知道的，
就说给他的爸爸和后妈买养老保险的，
我们结婚就住的那套房子呢，
在我外婆家楼上呢，
是他爷爷奶奶名下的那个房子呢，
是没有办理证的，
他的爸爸和后妈住的那套呢，
是他的名字，
也没有办证，
他是厂里的搞技术的，
他的工作也换来换去的，
有的时候上班，
有的时候就不上班，
我不知道他的具体收入，
结婚以后呢，
他每个月做上交2000块钱，
但是一年我感觉最多就交个半年的，
后来呢，
我女儿上幼儿园的时候呢，
我就考虑到她上。
小学的问题了，
我们这边开盘了一个楼，
看的那套呢是110万，
我的公积金呢是可以贷40的，
他和他家里呢一毛钱都没有出，
剩下的70呢，
是我妈妈一次性拿的，
因为是公积金贷款嘛，
去行政服务中心去办理的时候呢，
就要打我们两个的征信报告，
我就发现他有四整页满满的小额贷款陪我们一起去办理了，
那个售楼部的工作人员就悄摸的跟我说肯定是我，
我当时就非常的生气，
本身就一直想跟他分手的嘛，
我就拿着这四整页的纸，
我就拿到外婆家去，
我就说我要分手，
我妈妈，
我舅舅，
我哥哥听着呢，
就当没听见一样，
我妈妈是一直坚持不同意我分手的，
她说我性格强势又不好，
后来慢慢的呢，
我听说她婚前其实是输了70个的，
他们家底子很差，
没有钱，
你应该也是给他还了一部分的。
我是一个合同工，
每个月的工资就很少，
我还要还房贷嘛，
在20年的时候呢，
我就考上了事业编，
那个房子是19年12月份买的，
我考上事业编以后呢，
我的公积金就可以覆盖我的房贷了，
我还有副业，
我每年到手大概是15~20左右，
真的跟他过不来，
我就经常会提分手，
他一直就说房子可以给我女儿，
给他嘛，
因为是个女孩子，
我不可能。
给他的，
他本身品性就不太好嘛，
有一次呢，
我俩又说分手，
他说可以，
他自把就露出真面目了，
他就说女儿她不要，
一个月给抚养费2000，
他爸爸和他后妈住的那套房子呢，
在我女儿成年以后可以过户给我女儿，
因为我妈妈身体一直不太好，
我私自办理了这个分手证，
我就怕她吃出什么毛病，
所以呢，
这个事呢，
我们两个人去办了，
就没有说分手以后呢，
她正常付了一年左右的抚养费就没了，
二四年一整年的时候一毛钱都没有付，
二四年一月份的时候呢，
我妈妈就检查出来那个不好的病嘛，
我们就一直在家里面的医院和外地的医院治疗，
都是我和我爸爸在陪护的，
治疗了八个多月以后呢，
就还是没有挽留生命，
我后事办完了以后，
我就起诉他了，
一开始找的统治中心来调节的，
就让他把之前的一年多的抚养费分批给我，
他付了几个月以后呢，
又一毛钱都没有了，
我又去起诉他了，
我现在属于排队等待执行的阶段，
我经常能听到我身边的朋友啊，
你家的亲戚都在说他找谁，
又借他差别人几千块钱。
我的问题是他的房子和他爷爷奶奶那套房子都没有办证，
离婚协议上面不是说了这个房子等我女儿18岁以后呢过户吗？
他家已经卖了两套房子，
我有什么办法能保？
找过户口，
女儿的那套房子不被卖掉吗？
那套房子实际上是爷爷奶奶的财产是吧？
实际上并不是你的这个前夫她自己打拼下来的财产，
对不对？
他一毛钱存款都没有，
他那妹差出很多的钱，
那这个东西很难做到，
因为本就不属于他的东西。
他在离婚协议里面，
就好像是你跟张三离婚，
张三说把李四的财产给孩子一样，
不是回迁房，
是他的名字，
只是没有办证，
如果当时的拆迁政策他是属于权利主体，
那还有可能，
但你现在没有办证的情况下，
是没有办法落到孩子的名下的，
你想要这套房子不被他霍霍，
有一种可能性，
跟公公和公公的后老伴儿商量一下，
你去住那套房子，
你给公公和公公的后老伴儿租一套房子，
这样的话想卖想干嘛的话，
没那么容易，
那房子就是毛坯，
都没有装修，
我是不可能去住的啊，
就算是毛坯我跟你说啊，
通上水通上电的话，
你去住的话，
最起码他不容易卖出去，
因为任何人想要买房子，
是不是得来看看房子呀，
咱了解一下这个情况呀，
要么这个事儿你就别惦记了，
孩子以后自己打拼啊，
因为离婚协议上面是这么写的，
我的想法也就。
就是说能给我女儿是最好的，
不能给我也不打算要。
还有一个就是信用卡，
刚结婚没多久呢，
他跟我说他的朋友输了钱，
不敢告诉他老婆喊我借钱给他这个朋友，
我没有同意，
因为我手上有很多张信用卡，
他喊我把信用卡借给他刷，
他说回头朋友还他了再帮我还。
当时也年轻，
不懂，
我寻思只要不从我手上拿钱就行了，
我就把卡给他了，
三张卡大概是3万块钱，
就一直这样倒来倒去的。
后来他应该是找了一个养卡的人来养那张卡，
我后来发现其实就是他自己钱借我的卡去还他的账了。
我停了两张，
现在还有一张大额的，
里面是2万块钱的卡，
养卡的人每次转5000套5000，
还5000套5000，
这样子就停不了了，
养卡的人他还款日那天就老是这样大额的刷新，
刷出信用卡也给我打电话了，
就给我的卡就降额，
这养卡的人又不按时还，
我女儿现在三年级嘛，
我还想给我女儿以后再买一套那房子，
我就怕影响我的征信。
关于信用卡的问题，
我应该怎么办呢？
你立刻停掉这张信用卡，
里面欠多少钱，
当自己倒霉，
保住你的信用，
你的信用比这1万多块钱值钱，
而且你这个行为立刻停掉，
严格意义上来说是违法的，
马上停掉这张卡，
里面欠多少钱，
自己认栽还。
好，
保住你的信用哦，
好的，
还有就是我的爸爸呢，
他的性格就比较古怪，
从小我们两个人都不怎么合得来，
我们两个也很少交流，
他一直是在外地工作，
之前的工资呢都是给我妈妈的，
她经常在朋友圈里面就会发一大段的小作文呢，
说自己孤独什么的。
我们家两套回迁房呢，
写的都是我的名字，
当时呢，
我妈妈是喊我办证的，
19年的时候，
我不是买了一套商品房嘛，
我想把那套房子作为首套房子，
税交少一点，
所以三套房到现在呢都没有办证。
我妈妈走了以后，
有一天突然我爸爸就给我打电话，
说让我把两套房子办证，
写我的名字，
就说过年他不回来了，
我妈妈是九月份，
我当时挂完电话以后我就哭了挺久的，
我们两个人就没有什么话说，
我们每次联系的时候，
他说话很伤我的心。
李小问我的问题是什么呢？
我爸妈在以前的单位呢，
他老板呢，
就拖欠了他小两年的工资，
我们起诉了那个老板，
大概是65左右，
妈妈生前呢就一直惦记着这笔钱，
妈妈走了以后呢，
爸爸一直都说这个钱呢要给我女儿上学，
今年十月份的时候呢，
我爸爸说那个老板要还她一部分，
那个老板资产被冻结的，
说用不了，
我也不是很懂，
我爸爸就先协商，
让他给他30个，
我就跟我爸爸说，
这个钱你就放在我手上存，
给我女儿上学，
他又说他要自己存了。
以后等他死了再给我，
你想问我的问题是什么呢？
我就说这笔钱我是放我手上存的，
还是就放在爸爸那里吗？
我觉得每个人都需要安全感的，
换位思考一下，
如果你是一个老人，
跟女儿感情又不亲，
两套房子都登记在女儿的名下，
请问你手上要不要留点钱防老，
留点钱防身，
他手上应该还是有几十岁的，
说到底那是人家的钱，
是你爸爸挣的钱，
我爸爸他属于那种比较单纯的，
我们就怕他被别人给批量了，
这个钱这是你爸爸自己做主的事儿啊，
你也没有办法替他做主，
这是你爸爸的工资，
是他自己赚的钱，
血汗钱，
他自己能做主的事儿啊，
行好。
我有的时候就会觉得晚上睡不着觉的时候，
就经常会失眠，
就会想妈妈，
就会想，
小时候你也会觉得生活就特别的迷茫，
就是问问你，
你觉得我以后有什么规划吗？
你的生活已经比绝大多数人生活都要好了，
两套拆迁房落到你的名下，
你又是独生女，
爸爸现在又没有拖你的后腿，
你就带着个孩子，
你俩就过，
你真的已经很好了，
已经比绝大部分人的状态多好啊，
现在又没有人在情绪上去内耗，
你已经变成前夫了，
他过得怎么烂，
包他怎么借钱也跟你没有关系了，
你现在这个状态多好啊，
我觉得还是要跟你的爸爸去过。
人了，
还是要把他接回来，
让他感觉到温暖，
让他感觉到不管怎么样的话，
没有话说，
那就让孩子跟他玩啊。
比如说我们家农村有一套宅基地，
是我爸爸的，
旁边呢有一个古镇，
他总是问我去不去那边装修一下什么的，
我说现在大环境也不好，
我手上也没有什么钱装修他，
我说又不住，
就算搞民宿的话，
旁边有很多肯定也挣不了什么钱的，
我说那个房子就放在那里，
我说如果别人要租的话，
就租给别人。
我爸爸有6个侄子，
他说如果我要是不装修不翻心的话，
他就把房子给他的侄子。
我当时就很生气，
我就说你有女儿，
你也有孙女儿，
她做生意的，
开厂的。
我说他一个月的工资比你一年的都多，
你为什么要把那个房子给你家侄子呢？
我说你侄子又不是说吃不起那个饭了，
又不是说养不起两个孩子，
她说试探一下你的，
我先跟你想法律上的事情啊，
情理上的事情，
你自己再琢磨琢磨，
法律上的事情啊，
在你名下的财产呢，
你做主，
在你爸爸名下的财产，
尤其是他自己挣的工资，
他将来挣的钱，
他自己都可以做主，
他愿意给谁，
是法律赋予他的自由和权利，
他已经把两套拆迁房过户登记在你的名下了，
某种意义上他和你妈妈之间的这个账了了，
为什么呢？
因为从法律上来说，
举个例子，
你爸爸假设有。
200万，
其中100万是你妈妈的遗产，
你和你爸爸，
包括你妈妈的父母如果在的话，
还可以去分你妈妈的遗产。
我想跟你讲的意思是，
你爸爸已经把两套房过户到你名下了，
基本上没有办证，
如果你去办证，
他也配合你去办证，
基本上可以说是把大部分的财产都给到你了，
你妈妈去世的这个账也就了了，
剩下的钱都是你父亲他自己的，
他愿意给谁给谁，
这是法律赋予他的权利和自由。
我为什么让你说跟你爸要走的近一点，
因为如果你不走的近一点，
就有张三李四王五，
各种侄子侄女、
外甥外甥女，
他们走的近一点，
他给谁都是给我，
理解我的苦心了吗？
那咱俩就聊到这儿，
好好好，
谢谢老开，
你们不要以为说老年人一定是跟自己的亲儿子亲闺女关系就怎么怎么样吧，
那未必。
人老了之后跟小孩一样，
谁跟他玩儿能玩到一块儿去，
谁跟他逗闷子，
谁给他糖吃，
谁哄他开心，
他就跟谁亲。
我直播间有没有你是亲生儿女，
但你爸妈就偏心，
偏心侄子偏心，
外甥偏心这个偏心那个的就不偏心你有没有人老了之后跟小孩一样，
谁能跟他玩儿到一块儿去，
谁能哄他开心，
谁能让他感觉到温暖，
他就偏心谁。
越老活明白了之后，
就会觉得血缘这个东西没有那么重要。
记得点赞关注哦。